have you ever wondered what Bioshock in
space would be like you know what two
more I absolutely have well Lucy you are
in for a treat today because we're going
to be showing the viewers you guys at
home the alkanes pray might just be it
the pray re-imagination mmm the
imagining of pray yep
so we played the game for like an hour
um and we played from the very beginning
so I've skipped I've put together some
gameplay Clips here that we're talking
over but I've cut a big spoiler ething
massive spoiler massive so we can talk
about our general impressions of what we
think so in a minute um my I mean it
basically is Bioshock in space it feels
very similar
I mean arcane did actually work a little
bit on Bioshock 2 and there were a lot
of inspirations I think so here you can
tell I'm playing as Morgan I'm holding a
wrench mmm and that I can smack people
or on the Facebook yeah that's that's
nice buy as much Bioshock as you can get
yeah wrench the only thing that's
missing now is lightning in water well
but also another game that it really
reminds me a lot of is deus ex skulking
around like hacking into people's
computers reading their emails if you
like environmental storytelling boy this
game does have loved it yeah there's a
lot of stuff on the walls emails to read
comics to pick up that kind of thing
yeah cool little messages here and there
just left it's it's very much Deus Ex
and you know arcane are doing a great
job of kind of picking up and on that
lookingglass legacy with thief and
dishonored and now a bit of you know
deus ex in in prey which I'm all for and
they haven't made a bad game yet well in
a long time so I'm very very excited
about this and from what I played so far
I'm I'm really quite looking forward to
it we're skipping between different
areas here because yeah you know we want
to show off as much as the game as
possible but you do have a hub world so
you're only tell us one yeah it's kind
of like a space station and here we're
in the sales department mm-hmm and it's
it's very again don't want to hammer
this point home too much but it is quite
by sure yes you see at the
we're kind of picking stuff up things
like Facebook gloves and a used cigar
that someone's just left hanging around
room to stub those out
yeah cause fires but what you can do
with these items is you can use an thing
called a fabricator and sort of use it
to to craft yeah and so like you're
seeing stuff here like it is giving you
very the options of navigating
environments in various different ways
so because we weren't able to get
through that door with the passcode or
the ID card we've actually noticed that
there's a pipe that goes above I never
saw that the first time no and when you
say noticed you mean we're told at the
words yeah because they were fed up of
us just hot just from that knocking
around that door it's been like why
iconic so like it is it is giving you a
lot of up again biosex watch this okay
look two bins yeah what are the teens in
a bathroom oh so that's what this game
is about these mimic aliens so little
buggers see they're like little
skittering spiders that I found to be
quiet
what again like a bin this is like this
is the game telling you watch out there
is a mimic at the top of the stairs me
in my you know nonchalance going oh yeah
is it big look the bin is there oh come
on and then BAM yeah I get God so to
watch out yeah these things they remind
me like they're a mix between obviously
they've got this shape-shifting ability
but they also kind of like the headcrabs
from half-life yes where they appear out
of no way and they make the shrilling
sound and you just like gives it like
makes your hair stand on end but another
arcane reference there yeah they were
cancelled half pile of dead yep and like
I saw you can actually if you're quick
enough you can actually see a mimic
turning into something in the
environment so I seem like dashing
around and quickly just sort of freaking
out and going turn to smug so this gun
is a very effective against them so you
just freeze them basically it's
basically like maze ice gun yeah exactly
slow them down calm down freeze them and
then you can whack them with you and
these these mimics they do this really
really cool thing where they kind of
adopt this threatening starts when you
get close to them they're like a snake
so if you get get close to the limbs
really like elongate as if they trying
to
like get you to back up a bit and it's
quite freaky so here obviously you've
got your you've got guns you got the
glue gun you've got your wrench you've
also got these things called neuro mods
which are basically like power e type
thing yeah yeah moods so there's a
various amount of skill trees and stuff
that you can upgrade you can hack you
can repair you can turn into a mug sadly
not in this demo with international bugs
there's more than what you're seeing on
screen because a lot of some of them are
tied to weapons and specific items are
tied to your suit as well yeah so you
can upgrade that stuff so we kind of
looked through and a lot of the early
stuff was just basically boost to
engineering crafting that kind of stuff
this bit maybe income sparked yeah I do
not like the idea I've got a bit Doctor
Who at this point I was like you doctor
but yeah and as you can see like our
Keynes ability to create these really
interesting looking worlds is on in full
effect here oh yeah I spent a great deal
of time during our hour just looking at
little you know flourishes in the
environmental posters and that kind of
stuff so here I've activated my newer
mod which is basically I've gone a bit
bullet-time I've gone a bit Max Payne
slow down time to deal with this gang of
mimics and then I give up on him with my
red the bullets are not like in
abundance in this game like I found that
it does control how much ammo you have
and partly because I think that's partly
because they want you to kind of
experiment with a lot more weaponry than
just yeah they don't want you to find
your favor and keep it they want you to
kind of feel like you're kind of just
getting by on what you have so I really
appreciate it I love the name of this
new it's like a Wii game yeah there's a
lot of backtracking that you need to do
you'll notice that some terminals for
example you can't you can't access
console maybe you haven't got the right
nodes activated you can't hack so you
have to go back and get stuff you have
to retrace your steps a lot to get into
rooms this guy is called a phantom so
he's basically like you're not really a
mimic he's just yeah he's like something
in between like a Houdini splice yeah
exactly
he likes to he likes to keep on the move
so I mean you can get as you saw you can
get a healthy amount of his a um Oh
health out you get a big amount of his
health away but he usually runs runs
away quickly and you chase him down
I like that mean we've got a quick
glimpse of the inventory system here um
it's quite like it reminds me a lot of
Resident Evil um so limit in amount of
space and you have to do some hot
inventory management to make sure that
you can pick up everything that you need
you can also auto auto arrange and I
will just move everything around on its
own but where's the fun in that condo my
country oh it messes with your mind a
lot it does see the thing that we caught
out in the beginning is a really good
like oh snap moment yeah yeah again
didn't really want to show it yeah yeah
but if you want you're going to be
putting up the first 20 minutes or so
gameplay yeah on the on the game short
YouTube channel if you want to kind of
well if you want to spoil it a bit and
kind of but I feel like it it's it's a
good kind of setting it sets the kind of
tone of the of the game because you see
that and you're like oh so that's what
they're going for I understand and I
anticipate there's going to be a few
more twists and turns so I imagine
that's the least surprising twist of the
of the game so I definitely recommend
checking out that video so we got a
bunch more stuff going up about prey on
game for calm and on youtube.com slash
game so what make sure to throw us a
like and a subscribe while you're there
if you haven't already find tomorrow and
I on Twitter I'm at tomorrow hey I'm at
least James games and I'll see you next
time in a moment I'm going to ask you
what
you